[Music]
you're going to get knocked down a long
business relationship will come to a
sudden end the contract won't be renewed
a lover will call it a day people will
suddenly be weird with you they'll keep
you out of lovely things and you won't
know why you'll read about yourself on
social media and every worst fear will
be confirmed quite a lot of things go
wrong over a lifetime and you'll want to
die and throw it all in and quit as
painful world when you look at a child
this is what's coming to them that's
what makes it moving to look at a baby
sleeping you're looking at innocence
through the lens of painful experience
oh my they're going to suffer and
there's simply nothing you can do to
help them about whom one thing teach
them that the suffering is normal it
isn't a sign that life is gone wrong
it's an ordinary part of everyone's
biography the only way is to learn to
fight the temptation will be to withdraw
under a rock to pull up the drawbridge
to go into a shell but the challenges
are like a fire a bed of coals you have
to walk across the fight is to be
expected the difficulties are a sign
that things are on track that you're
being rejected that there are haters
isn't evidence that your life is a world
it's proof that you found something
worth living for
[Music]
you